thank you
so
9243rd meeting of the Security Council
is called to order
the provisional agenda for this meeting
is
maintenance of peace and security of
Ukraine
the agenda is adopted
in accordance with rule 37 of the
council's provisional rules of procedure
I invite the representatives of ritania
Poland and the Ukraine to participate in
this meeting
it is so decided
the accordance with rule 39 of the
council's provisional rules of procedure
I invite Ms Rosemary dicolo under
Secretary General for political and
peace building Affairs to participate in
this meeting
it is so decided
in accordance with rule 39 of the
council's provisional rules of procedure
I also invite his Excellency Mr Olive
skug head of the delegation of the
European Union to the United Nations to
participate in this meeting
it is so decided
the security Council will now begin its
consideration of item 2 of the agenda
I now give the floor to Ms Rosemary
decalo
thank you Mr President
the war in Ukraine is approaching its
one-year anniversary with no end in
sight to the fighting or the suffering
throughout the holiday season
the forces of the Russian Federation
continued their strikes on key Ukrainian
cities
too many ukrainians spent what is
normally a festive period in bomb
shelters
far from celebrating countless families
across the country were mourning the
loss of loved ones
on the morning of 29 December Russian
forces launched more ukraine-wide
attacks targeting regions including
nepro her son kirovarad and Kiev
multiple strikes were reported in the
cities of harkif Adesa leave
as well as Kiev
two days later on New Year's Eve
Ukraine's all-administrative regions
were again under air raid warnings
the attacks have continued in the New
Year despite the announcement of a
possible secession of hostilities over
Orthodox Christmas a holy period for
both Russians and ukrainians
on 6 January an emergency worker was
killed in an attack on a fire station in
the city of her son
the next day several regions in the east
and south of Ukraine were shelled
ground fighting has intensified
especially in the Donetsk region
in areas of active hostilities such as
balmut and soledadar
Relentless battles including street
fighting pose a great threat to the
remaining civilian population
in bakmud alone
the office of the High Commissioner for
human rights has documented 22 civilians
killed and 72 injured since early
December
following the most recent fighting
ohchr has verified 18
096 civilian casualties since Russia's
invasion of 24 February 2022
this total includes
6952 people killed and eleven thousand
one hundred forty four injured
the actual figures are likely
considerably higher
Mr President the war has forced Millions
to flee their homes
we commend the generosity of the
countries hosting some 7.9 million
people who sought protection in Europe
we encourage further efforts to ensure
Equitable access to rights and services
for refugees and National systems
in Ukraine some 5.91 million people
65 percent of them women and girls are
internally displaced
fueling the displacement is the
purposeful systematic targeting of civil
critical civilian infrastructure
including energy and health care
facilities
following a request from Ukraine to the
Secretary General the United Nations
development program has launched a
sector-specific damage assessment in
collaboration with the World Bank
the assessment which aims at identifying
the most critical needs for restoration
of damaged energy infrastructure is
currently underway with 90 percent of
the data collection completed
the number of recorded attacks on Health
Care Facilities last year was the
highest in the world
there were 745 incidents as of for
January
in the most affected regions in the east
and south of the country reportedly 15
percent of facilities are either
partially or completely non-functional
in up to 50 percent in Donetsk zaparesia
nikolaev and harkif
president inevitably
the war is also leaving invisible scars
according to the World Health
Organization
nearly a quarter of the population is
reportedly at risk of developing a
mental health condition because of this
war
the destruction and closing of schools
will also have a lasting impact on
children and young people
an estimated 5.7 million school-aged
children have been directly affected
including 3.6 million due to the closure
of educational institutions early in the
conflict
in recent months eight organizations
have continued efforts to expand
life-saving operations to previously
inaccessible areas including in harkif
and her son regions
as of 5 January humanitarian Partners
have provided food to almost 9 million
people
the same number of people have received
critical health care support across the
country
around 7.3 million people have been
assisted with access to clean water and
hygiene products over 3 million people
uprooted by the war are those whose
houses have been damaged have received
emergency shelter or critical household
items
in response to the energy crisis
humanitarian Partners have distributed
hundreds of generators to make sure
critical services like hospitals and
schools as well as centers hosting those
displaced can continue operating
in all since 24 February of last year
almost 14 million people have received
assistance from over 740 partners
this includes one million people in
areas not under the control of the
government of Ukraine
a Tyrion response is hampered by severe
access constraints particularly in areas
in the East under Russian control
in line with International humanitarian
law parties must facilitate rapid and
unimpeded passage of humanitarian relief
for all civilians in need
Mr President ohchr continues to document
allegations of grave human rights
violations and to support efforts
towards accountability
since 24 February ohchr has documented
over 90 cases of conflict-related sexual
violence falling into two categories
the majority as a method of torture and
ill treatment in detention predominantly
affecting men
and sexual violence involving rape
including gang rape of women and girls
in areas under Russian control
it is imperative that all perpetrators
of human rights violations are held
accountable
and on the question of accountability
the office of the prosecutor of the
international criminal court continues
its work in Ukraine
where it has maintained a presence since
May 2022.
as the prosecutor has indicated in his
briefings to the council
the alleged targeting of Civilian
objects and the unlawful transfer and
deportation of civilians including
children from Ukraine to the Russian
Federation are the investigative
priorities of his office
Mr President on a positive note
we welcome the ongoing contacts and
commitment of the parties to continue
exchanges of prisoners of War most
recently on Sunday involving 50
Ukrainian and 50 Russian captives
we're encouraged by the meeting hosted
in Turkey on 11 January of Russian and
Ukrainian ombuds persons on this issue
despite the challenging context the
Black Sea grain initiative continues to
make a difference including by helping
bring Global food prices down
the food and agriculture organization
now reports a continued decline of its
food Price Index
more than 17 million metric tons of
foodstuffs have now been moved under the
initiative reaching or on their way to
some 43 countries
roughly 20 percent of this total is for
countries categorized by the World Bank
as low income or lower middle income
economies
the United Nations also continues its
engagement with all stakeholders to
remove remaining obstacles to Russian
food and fertilizer exports including
ammonia
these exports are key
to keep prices down and mitigate food
insecurity and we ate we urge all
concerns to work to that end
Mr President as the Secretary General
has made clear
Russia's invasion of Ukraine is a
violation of the charter of the United
Nations and of international law
it has created a humanitarian and human
rights catastrophe
dramatized a generation of children and
accelerated the global food and energy
crises
and yet this great damage could pale in
comparison with the consequences of a
prolonged conflict
I said at the outset of my statement
that there is no sign of an end to the
fighting
the logic that prevails is a military
one with very little if any room for
dialogue right now
but all wars end and so too will this
one
Ukraine Russia the world cannot afford
for this war to continue
the Secretary General is ready to assist
the parties to end this senseless
unjustified conflict on the basis of the
United Nations Charter and international
law thank you Mr President
I thank Mr Carlo for her briefing
I now give the floor
to those council members who wish to
make a statement
I give the floor to the representative
of Albania
thank you Mr President and thank you
usgd Carlo for yet another in-depth
briefing on the ongoing situation in
Ukraine
Mr President's colleagues
a year has passed and the situation in
Ukraine is no different
323 days of an ongoing unjust and
unjustified War have resulted in
devastating damage to the population
and the country's physical economic and
human infrastructure infrastructure
thousands of civilians have been killed
some 8 million have been refugees become
refugees a large part of the population
is suffering from psychological trauma
despite worldwide condemnation and
rejection despite the huge human toll in
human lives despite everything Russia
continues on the same course
civilians and their families in Ukraine
have an or enduring escalating
Devastation children's continue to be
killed wounding and deeply traumatized
by the violence all around them
endless individual traumas tell the
larger story
take this story here's love a 13 years
old boy was waiting the new year with
his family in priyanska
when their home came on the Russian fire
seriously wounded he was taken to the
hospital in Kirsten
but in the first few minutes of 2023 the
Russian army shelved the hospital and
yaroslav was evacuated to another one in
mikolai where doctors continue to fight
for his life hopefully with success in
disguise
how many other
children boys girls have seen their
Destiny of the mercy of a war they do
not want and they do not understand
Mr President among a myriad of disasters
inflicted upon Ukraine there is one
particular striking as much as hurting
there are no more children left in
Ukraine
and I'm not speaking about those who
have been killed without getting to
understand the world they were born in
I'm not speaking about those who were
forced to leave everything behind to
flee a war inflicted by those claiming
to be their brothers
and I'm not speaking about those tens of
thousands deported and given for
adoption but to strangers in Russia no
I'm speaking about those premature
adults of little age in Ukraine
those who have been forced to grow up
years in months
those forced to face killing tanks and
not play with soldiers toys
those who cannot attend school because
it has been destroyed
those who cannot sleep by fear of a
missile falling on the roof
those who have no more tears left to cry
their misery
Mr President
since the very first day of this war
we and the absolute majority in this
organization have made a fundamental
distinction
Russia is the aggressor state
Ukraine is fighting to defend itself for
survival
Russia is wrong and nothing can or will
ever change this and no propaganda
machine has been able to alter it
Ukrainian Army and people have defied
all expectations
we applaud the heroic resistance and
Military billions in the face of a
brutal invasion
this is why it has been and remains
crucial to help ukrainians to defend
themselves and Prevail in restoring
their sovereignty in securing their
borders because
any other result will only sharpen the
kremlin's appetite
let's not forget only eight years
separated Russia's Caesar of Crimea and
the invasion of Ukraine
those who believe being on a Messianic
mission to restore falling Empires will
not stop if they are not stopped
they will just wait until the next move
the world needs Ukraine within its
borders to save a world order from the
current and future transgressors of
commonly agreed rules
Ukraine has been able to show the world
the strength of the right against the
illusions of the might
in this conflict it is the courage and
resilience of ukrainians that represent
the hope for a life in peace for all of
us
Mr President
since February last year the course of
the war has forced multiple times Russia
to Define down its military to go its
military goals
Russia abandoned the key of era because
it was forced out
Crimean officials declared that Russia
is in cursing forever and then they were
forced out
all the ground lost in 2022 has not
resulted for any from any tactical
retreat but from outright defeat
the coming has not changed has not
changed its goals it has been contained
and stopped this is why it is important
to continue to support Ukraine by
providing political military financial
and humanitarian support and assistance
Ukrainian Heroes fighting for freedom
for all of us
for what we believe in for what we stand
for need and deserve modern weapons to
push back their invader
this is even more evident given the
realities on the ground
this month we see more and more a war of
Rage a Bloodshed of proportions a war of
attrition
solidar has rightly recalled pounded for
months and where nothing is any more
standing now resembles mariopol let's
not forget it
the footprint of an absolute insanity
reporters speak of a meat grinding
machine where Wagner group is using
human lights as scanning footer
Mr President it has become a pattern
every time Russia has been installing an
in difficulty on the ground it has
deliberately targeted its critical
infrastructure in particular Ukraine's
electricity distribution grid and power
generation capacity by the way a blatant
War crime thanks also to the extensive
views of the Iranian drones acquired
illegally in breach of the security
Council resolution 2231 and for which we
are still waiting Clarity for from the
secret
it has force it has tried to force
Ukraine into a submission it has failed
ukrainians may be without electricity
without water supply and heating but
they have a heart a fighting heart for
their country for their freedom for the
right to be themselves
but let's not forget sooner or later
Lord responsible for crimes committed
will have to face their acts and pay for
their actions
Mr President like every other war in
history this one will stop one day
it should not have started in the first
place but it it is never late to stop it
unrealistic and insincere calls for
talks while wrecking Havoc to the
country killing its civilians and the
next thing is territories by force won't
lead anywhere
the crimes committed against Ukrainian
civilians the rapes and murders the
scales of Destruction the sacrifices and
the number of deaths the persisting
imperialist madness have not broken
Ukraine and we all know it
they only have strengthened the resolve
the ukrainians to defend themselves and
bar the way to the aggressor
for any meaningful incredible diplomatic
path to materialize Russia must first
withdraw it through from the
internationally recognized borders of
Ukraine this can lead to an outcome I
thank you
I thank the representative of Albania
for their statement I now give the floor
to uh to the representative of the
United States
thank you Mr President
under Secretary General DeCarlo thank
you for your briefing Deputy foreign
minister zaparova thank you for joining
us today
on January 1st as the rest of us were
celebrating and welcoming the new year
the people of Ukraine endured three
straight nights of Russian missiles and
drone strikes against their cities
these attacks were barbaric they
destroyed systems that provide heat and
light to the Ukrainian people during the
coldest darkest part of winter
they're not the actions of a country
ready to give up on War
this New Year offers us along with our
new colleagues on the council an
opportunity to reflect on the last year
let's start by reminding ourselves of
the Mandate of this body
the Security Council is the primary body
responsible for the maintenance of
International Peace and security
that is a serious solemn Duty the U.N
Charter and the peace it strives to
achieve
is in our hands it's in our care
last January we feared this peace was at
risk
12 months ago the United States first
warned a troubling signs that Russia was
planning a massive full-scale invasion
of Ukraine
as Russia amassed troops along the
Ukrainian border including in Belarus we
rang alarm bells and pursued every
diplomatic Avenue possible to prevent
War
in January 2022 we convened urgent
meetings including at the osce the
nato-russia council and the bilateral
U.S Russia strategic stability dialogue
our goal was for all sides to resolve
their concerns through dialogue and
diplomacy
but Russia chose a different path
President Putin chose to strike at the
heart of the U.N Charter
he chose War
at the exact moment in fact that we were
working in this Council to keep the
peace
today we're all feeling the direct
end spillover effects of this senseless
War
for example Russia's war in Ukraine has
dramatically exacerbated the global food
crisis the world food program estimates
that more than 345 million people are
suffering from are at risk of acute food
insecurity acute that means they are in
imminent danger of dying
345 million people that's more than
double the amount in 2019.
Russia's attacks and continued blocking
of some Ukrainian ports have decreased
Ukraine's food exports by approximately
30 percent
and we thank turkia and the U.N
Secretary General for helping to broker
the Black Sea grain initiative which has
been critical to feeding the world's
hungry
but here's the truth the initiatives
operations are not keeping Pace with the
strong Global demand for Black Sea grain
due to Russia's deliberate slowdown of
inspections dozens of ships are waiting
to depart and dozens more are waiting
for inspections before they can bring
their grain cargo to the world
this backlog means extra expense and
extra delay for millions of tons of
grain a majority of which is destined
for developing countries
the backlog means 2.5 million tons of
brain are just sitting there waiting to
move and farmers in Ukraine are waiting
to plant
some ships have been waiting for over a
month grain is moving at just half the
rate of the pace back in September and
October
the initiative should operate as it was
envisioned moving 5 million tons of food
per month the world's hungry deserve
nothing less
today I'm asking members of the council
to join us in urging Russia to scale up
cooperation immediately
as we work to contain the ripple effect
of Russia's War we must also be laser
focused on the horrors happening in
Ukraine on the ground
last week the New York Times detail the
Herring accounts from the Ukrainian
prosecuted General's office of
well-documented cases of sexual violence
committed against women men and children
by Russian Federation forces I strongly
encourage everyone everyone at this
table to listen uh listening here today
to read this report
the details are too awful too sickening
for me to recount here today of course
we don't only have to rely on the New
York Times the un's independent
International Commission of inquiry has
documented numerous reports reported
cases of sexual violence and torture
just as just as when we warn this
Council last January that Russia was
planning a full-scale invasion of
Ukraine we also warned this Council more
recently that Iran and the dprk planned
to transfer prohibited materials to
Russia they have
since August Iran has transferred
hundreds of uavs to Russia in violation
of U.N security Council resolution 2231.
Russia has been using these Iranian uavs
to strike Ukraine's energy
infrastructure just depriving millions
of Ukrainian civilians of electricity
heat and critical services in the middle
of winter
people in Ukraine today are suffering
and dying as a result of Iran's support
We Believe Iran is now considering the
cell of hundreds of ballistic missiles
to Russia and also in violation of
council resolutions we urge Iran to
reverse course and not to take these
steps
and we urge everyone who supports peace
to ask Iran to do the same
meanwhile dprk officials said publicly
that they would not support Russia's war
in Ukraine but they have since delivered
arms to the Wagner group in direct
violation of Security Council
resolutions last month dprk delivered
infantry rockets and missiles into
Russia for use by Russian Federation
back Wagner in violation of the
council's sanctions resolution
and we're concerned that the dprk is
planning to deliver more military
equipment to Wagner
we condemn the dprk's actions and urge
the dprk to cease these deliveries and
come into compliance with the relevant
Security Council resolutions and once
again we encourage everyone to join us
in that call
Mr President as we start this New Year
the world is tired of War
the people of Ukraine who have suffered
so much craved to return to a normal
life now is the time for all countries
to stand together and demand that Russia
in this senseless War
we must come together in defense of the
UN Charter and its most fundamental
principles we must come together to
achieve a just and secure peace
consistent with the charter
and let us continue to do everything in
our power to contain the Ripple effects
of Russia's actions help those who are
suffering both in Ukraine and outside
its borders and hold accountable
everyone who violates international law
and supports this illegal immoral War
thank you
I thank the representative of United
States for their statement now I give
the floor to the representative of
Ecuador
Gracia thank you very much Mr President
I'm grateful to uh under Secretary
General for
political and peacebuilding Affairs
Rosemary DeCarlo
for her briefing
since this is the first opportunity that
my delegation has had to
refer to this
topic a central topic on the agenda of
the security Council I want to just
stress that since the very beginning of
the military aggression of Russia
against Ukraine Ecuador has condemned it
unequivocally
this aggression against the sovereignty
and territorial Integrity of Ukraine
is contrary to the principles of the
United Nations Charter
and to international law and it has no
place
in an international order based on the
rule of law
as
stated by our foreign minister olgin in
the open debate and this Security
Council yesterday
now a pursuant to the principles of our
foreign policy and remaining faithful to
our vocation as a peace-loving nation we
do not recognize nor will we ever
recognize
the acquisition of territory by force
we'd like to express our support
to the Secretary General Antonio
guterres
for the
efforts to achieve peace undertaken as
part of one of the most complex
challenges
represented by this conflict and any
other conflict that involves one of the
permanent members of this Council
Ecuador regret regrets Mr President the
partial
application of article 27.3 of the UN
Charter
that is the article from which The veto
is derived but that article also
establishes the obligation for the
parties in a dispute to refrain or
rather to abstain from voting
uh
furthermore I'd like to highlight
resolution 2623 of 2022 in which the
members of the security Council decided
to convene 11th extraordinary
session of the general assembly
which
allowed the members of this organization
to
Express their position
with determination my delegation recalls
the
presidential statement of the security
Council of the 6th of May of 2022 in
which this
very organ
demonstrated Unity
in expressing its profound concern about
maintaining peace and Security in and in
Ukraine and
recognize that pursuant to the United
Nations Charter and I quote all member
states have assumed the obligation to
resolve their dis international disputes
through peaceful means end of quote
the security Council and its members
must honor that declaration
or we therefore
urge that an end be put to this Invasion
that will soon markets one year
anniversary and we urge that this
Council examine
ways that make it possible to
immediately suspend hostilities and to
re-establish
peace and Security in Ukraine
those that are based on the respect of
its sovereignty territorial integrity
and political Independence
Ecuador is ready to support any
initiative
that
promotes political dialogue and
diplomacy and that furthermore
eliminates the Specter of the nuclear
threat
Mr President
Ecuador
deplores the recent escalation of
attacks and Strikes in Ukraine
which continued to deteriorate the
humanitarian situation which has been
aggravated by
bombing targeting critical
infrastructure
that has decimated access to basic
Services furthermore we are
very concerned about the risk of
accidents or incidents on nuclear power
plants and on this point we'd like to
reiterate our wholehearted support to
the international atomic energy agency
iaea and would like to
reiterate
the need to facilitate its work
including on the ground in a way that is
safe and without any impediments
attacks against the energy
infrastructure against housing hospitals
various educational facilities these in
particular affect the most vulnerable
groups such are such as children and
older adults
even more
the
electricity Cuts caused by it these
attacks aggravate the suffering that the
Ukrainian population is experiencing in
the midst of a cold winter
these attacks also violate resolution 25
73 for the protection of facilities that
are essential for the survival of the
civilian population that was adopted in
April of 2021.
we would like to make an urgent appeal
that attacks against civilians cease and
that
International humanitarian law be
respected unconditionally
this conflict that is inflicting pain
and destruction on the people of Ukraine
has changed the Dynamics of this Council
and it has disastrous consequences that
have worsened food insecurity around the
world and on this point we call on the
expansion
and
deepening of initiatives such as the
Black Sea grain initiatives
the um
I'd like to recall I remind this Council
that just during the first month of this
military aggression against Ukraine
Ecuador had to evacuate almost 1 000 of
our citizens and particular students in
various humanitarian flights and lastly
in the humanitarian sphere Ecuador
acknowledges a leadership and
the efforts
throughout 2022
of Mexico and France
Mexico concluded this very valuable uh
role this past December for this reason
Ecuador will work very closely with
France to continue
promoting humanitarian issues in this
Council thank you very much
I thank the representative of icaro for
their statement I give the floor to the
representative of Mozambique
Mr President
Mozambique wishes to thank
the under Secretary General Rosemary
DeCarlo
for our useful
and comprehensive briefing
we welcome the participation in this
meeting
of other distinguished delegations
in particular
that of our Excellency Museum in
saparova
the first Deputy foreign minister of
Ukraine
in the company of our distinguished
colleague
his Excellency sergeya
the permanent representative of Ukraine
to the United Nations
Mr President
in his final address of the year last
December
Secretary General Antonio guterres
expresses cautious hope
that the year 2023
would bring an end
to this conflict
it was a hope
that
we then wholeheartedly embraced
we note however
that after almost a year of armed
conflict
the war shows a little sign of abating
the conflict
appears to thread the narrow path of
escalation
as we have heard from the report
of the USG di Carlo
we are a deeply concerned
that Europe
a continent at the origin of two tragic
world wars
and the epicenter of a Long Cold War
is again plunging the world
into a gloomy situation or fear and food
crisis
we are here
to encourage
that weighs over negotiated solution to
the conflict
be
explored
we have a genuine interest in peace and
security
worldwide
as a global common good
we wish to remind ourselves
that the concept of collective security
that the security of one is the security
of War
was at the center of the creation of the
United Nations
it is a concept enshrined in the charter
and cherished by all peace loving
Nations
in this connection
we can only welcome
the efforts of this body
to address the issue
Mozambique
hold the view
that there should be an immediate
cessation of hostilities
and a return to direct negotiations
between the belligerent parties
those negotiations
should be conducted in good faith by
both parties
in the spirit
of the purposes and principles of the
United Nations Charter
we defend
that humanitarian work be given a high
priority
in accordance with the relevant rules
of international humanitarian law
and practices of humanity
Mr President
we see the need and importance
ensuring up the platform
that led to the Black Sea initiative
with the support of the secretary
General's Global crisis response group
on food energy and finance
in this context
we encourage the Secretary General to
continue
devoting his efforts
with our support
and his moral Authority
in search for a negotiated solution to
the conflict
I thank you Mr President I thank the
representative representative of
Mozambique for their statement now I
give the floor to the representative of
Switzerland
president Mr President I wish to begin
by thanking under Secretary General
Rosemary De Carlo for her sober
assessment of the situation I also wish
to welcome here Among Us the first
Deputy foreign minister of Ukraine Her
Excellency
and I welcome his Excellency Mr Wichita
of Poland to this meeting I also welcome
the representatives of the other
delegations here present for the
population of Kev and many other regions
of Ukraine this year began as the last
one ended that is with a large wave of
airstrikes launched by Russia at the
same time intense fighting continues
particularly in the east of Ukraine our
thoughts are with the people who are
suffering from this war wherever they
are in the world
Mr President Russia's large-scale
military aggression against Ukraine is a
serious violation of international law
and of the UN Charter Switzerland
strongly condemns this violation and
fully supports the sovereignty and
territorial Integrity of Ukraine we call
upon Russia to immediately de-escalate
the situation we call upon them also to
cease all combat operations and to
withdraw without delay its troops from
the entire territory of Ukraine this
includes the territories declared as
annexed as an occupying power Russia
must respect its obligations under
International humanitarian rights law
Switzerland calls for rapid and
unhindered access of humanitarian Aid to
be guaranteed throughout Ukraine
including in areas occupied by Russia we
also condemn the involvement of Belarus
in Russia's military aggression
during an armed conflict the civilian
population pays far too higher price
their protection is a humanitarian
imperative
Switzerland stresses that all parties
must protect the civilian population as
well as persons order Comba all parties
must respect International humanitarian
law and human rights however in Ukraine
since February 2022 thousands of
civilians have died or have been injured
the Ukrainian people have been subjected
to and still face horrific situations
these include acts that the independent
International Commission of inquiry on
Ukraine considers to be war crimes and
human rights violations millions of
people have been forced to leave their
homes the vast majority of them are
women and children
these women and children have often been
exposed to high risks such as human
trafficking and sexual violence in
addition to all of this in recent months
there have been a recurrent Russian
attacks against Ukraine's energy
infrastructure without electricity the
functioning of essential services such
as hospitals and water supply systems is
hampered in view of all of the above I
today reiterate Switzerland coal for a
cessation of all attacks on civilians
and persons of the combat as well as
attacks against civilian property and on
essential infrastructure
we must take a step forward towards
peaceful just and Lasting Solutions this
involves a commitment to diplomatic
Solutions it also involves progress in
the Reconstruction process action on
accountability and victims rights and
involves redoubling efforts to guarantee
nuclear Safety and Security we must not
forget that this war has consequences
which go far beyond the European
continent the burden of more expensive
food uncertain energy Supply and the
threat of a nuclear incident way on the
whole world we share the secretary
General's conviction and I quote this is
not a time to sit on the sidelines it is
the time for resolve determination and
yes even hope end quote Switzerland
supports including as host state in
Geneva the good offices of the Secretary
General and his unwavering commitment to
advancing peace we will continue to
provide humanitarian Aid in Ukraine
we'll do this for example by supplying
mobile heating devices we support
Justice for victims including by
promoting the documentation and
investigation of crimes committed
against them we are committed to a
participatory in transparent
reconstruction process under Ukrainian
leadership this was set out by the
Lugano principles
Mr President last year war returned to
Europe with full force as members of
this Council it is our responsibility to
do everything in our power to ensure
that this year is a year of just peace
in accordance with international law in
Ukraine and elsewhere in the world thank
you thank the representative of
Switzerland for their statement I now
give the floor to the representative of
France
Mr President
I wish to thank Misty Carlo for her
briefing
soon it will be a year a year that
Ukraine has resisted with bravery and
determination the Russian aggression
which was Unleashed in violation of
international law and of the United
Nations Charter Russia had counted on
the rapid collapse of the Ukrainian Army
and its authorities 11 months later the
offensive on Kiev has been pushed back
the region of khakif and the City of
Kirsten have been liberated with each
victory of Ukraine on the ground Russia
reacts with cowardice by shelling
civilian infrastructure these strikes
have a very clear goal
that of sowing Terror among civilians
and breaking the morale of the Ukrainian
people the unilateral Announcement by
the Kremlin of a ceasefire that Russia
and its own reserves have not upheld is
additional evidence of Russia's cynicism
Mr President Russian strikes violate the
fundamental principles of international
humanitarian law and of international
criminal law these unacceptable acts
constitute war crimes and will not go
unpunished
France will continue to stand shoulder
to shoulder with Ukrainian courts and
with the international criminal court
stocks of Munitions in Russia are
diminishing and they're facing major
difficulties on the ground at the same
time Russia is seeking to get supplies
by all means possible including by
violating Security Council resolutions
moreover Russia is making extensive use
of drones surprised supplied by Iran the
United Nations must investigate these
transfers these violate resolution
2231 and the United Nations must ensure
Russia is held accountable to compensate
for these huge losses Russia does not
hesitate to mobilize Magna Wagner
mercenaries many criminals are among
Wagner's ranks the Russian aggression
has devastating consequences on Global
Food security Global Food security is
used by Russia as a weapon of war and as
an instrument of blackmail
the Black Sea grain initiative has
proven effective it has lowered the
price of foodstuffs and allowed these
food stuff to achieve those who need
them the most
several millions of tons of grain have
been exposed spotted the majority of
this material has gone to non-european
Nations we expect Russia to guarantee
the full implementation of this
agreement moreover we support tangible
initiatives taken by Ukraine France
has mobilized through the farm
initiative and as well as through the
European solidarity Lanes initiative Mr
President Russia continues its headlong
Rush forth and stepped up its abuses in
so doing Russia has consistently
demonstrated that it does not wish to
see peace Russia alone is responsible
for continued hostilities through the
10-point peace plan proposed by
president zielinski Ukraine is setting
forth the path towards a just and
Lasting peace this peace will only be
achieved if there is a full withdrawal
of Russian troops from the whole of the
of Ukrainian territory that is the only
way that it will be possible to put an
end to the suffering of the Ukrainian
people a people who fight courageously
for their freedom against this backdrop
France will continue to provide the
Ukrainian people with all necessary
support for them to exercise their right
to self-defense and so that they can
preserve their sovereignty territorial
integrity and Independence I thank you I
thank the representative of France for
their statement I give the floor to the
representative of China
Mr President
in his new year's message stated that in
2023 we need peace now more than ever
helping Ukraine and the European region
restore peace and stability
is an unshakable responsibility of the
International Community the security
Council in particular
and a goal that we should redouble our
efforts to achieve in the new year
I wish to make the full following four
observations
first to create conditions for dialogue
and negotiations the current situation
in Ukraine is the result of the
long-term accumulation and continuous
evolution of deep-seated security
imbalances in Europe
only when parties concerned overcome
their differences and sit down at the
negotiation table can we find the
fundamental solution to end the war and
rebuild the European security
architecture
the path of peace talks is not a smooth
one
but as long as we do not give up our
efforts
and demonstrate political determination
and wisdom
starting from little and practical
things
and gradually building up
the prospect of peace
will always be within reach
the International Community in
particular countries with major
influence on the current situation
should encourage Russia and Ukraine to
engage in dialogue
and help open a door to a political
solution to the crisis
escalating sanctions or providing
weapons
will only make it more difficult to turn
the situation around
and may even provoke larger scale
confrontations
thus exacerbating
and prolonging the conflict
which must be avoided at all costs
second
to spend no effort in alleviating the
humanitarian crisis the ongoing conflict
and the cold winter have added to the
humanitarian needs
many people have to face the reality of
shelling lack of water and electricity
and family separation while ushering in
the new year
parties to the conflict should
effectively uphold International
humanitarian law take measures to
protect civilians and civilian
infrastructure from attacks
and make every effort to reduce the
humanitarian consequences of the
conflict
continued International humanitarian
assistance is indispensable to help
conflict affected people survive the
winter
it is imperative to help Ukraine repair
damaged energy infrastructure as soon as
possible so that people can survive the
winter
and a larger scale humanitarian crisis
can be avoided
Russia's
36-hour ceasefire
over Orthodox Christmas
allowed people to spend a holiday in
peace
and provided favorable conditions for
the humanitarian agencies to deliver
their supplies which should be welcomed
we hope in future there will be more
similar ceasefire initiatives so as to
create conditions for a comprehensive
ceasefire
third to eliminate nuclear security
risks the shelling around the zaporizia
nuclear power plant has not seized and
its Safety and Security has been a
source of concern
according to the iaea
all six reactors at the plant are down
and the last backup power line to
guarantee the plant Safety and Security
functions was damaged by shelling at the
end of last December
with power transmission only resumed
last week
this should not happen again
and all military operations that could
affect the Safety and Security of the
nuclear power plant should be stopped
immediately
China supports the iaea in its
continuous communication with Russia and
Ukraine on the Safety and Security of
the zaparazia nuclear power plant in
order to reach a mutually acceptable
and a viable Arrangement at an early
date
fourth to contain a spillover effect of
the crisis
the covid-19 pandemic the conflict in
Ukraine and other crises are reinforcing
each other
with devastating impact on the
achievement of the sdgs
developing countries are suffering from
increasingly High inflation and debt
burdens
and in last year alone the number of
people suffering from extreme poverty
and severe hunger increased by several
million
it should be noted that this is not
simply about production and demand
and that the disruption of global
industrial chain and Supply Chain by
unilateral sanctions cannot be ignored
major developed countries should adopt
responsible economic monetary and trade
policies to avoid negative spillover
effects that exacerbate the economic and
livelihood difficulties of developing
countries not to mention using the world
economy as a political tool or weapon
thereby undermining
the hot one momentum of recovery
the Black Sea grain initiative has
brought hope to people in hunger
China welcomes the continued
implementation of the initiative and
encourages the U.N Secretariat to make
practical efforts in removing the
obstacles to the export of Russian food
and fertilizer
Mr President
the crisis in Ukraine has once again
brought the world to a Crossroads
as president Xi Jinping stated
whether to revert to the Cold War
mentality
unprovoked Division and confrontation or
to proceed from the common welfare of
the humanity and uphold equality mutual
respect and women cooperation
this is a test of the wisdom of the
International Community and the reason
of the humanity
facts have proved that conflict
confrontation containment and decoupling
are against the trend of the times and
therefore doomed to failure
while peace development wing wing and
cooperation are in line with the
expectation of the people and the
pervading trend of the times
at the beginning of the new year all
parties should take new actions to
actively open up new prospects for peace
China will continue to uphold an
objective and impartial position and
take constructive efforts in its own way
thank you Mr President
I thank the representative of China for
their statement
now I give the floor to the
representative of Brazil
Mr President
I welcome
the first Deputy foreign minister of
Ukraine MS japarova
the deputy for the deputy Minister of
Foreign Affairs of Poland Mr Gabriel
as well as the representatives of
Lithuania and the European Union to this
session
I thank under Secretary General Rosemary
DeCarlo for the detailed and
comprehensive briefing
which unfortunately confirms prevailing
somber expectations
we are sorry to hear once again
that there are no prospects for opening
peace negotiations
while the humanitarian situation
continues to deteriorate and the number
of Civilian casualties increases every
day
Brazil understands that initiatives such
as the temporary ceasefire during
Orthodox Christmas could pave the way
for the resumption of dialogue
it is heartbreaking to see that even in
such moments it is impossible to reach
agreement and yet another opportunity to
build peace was lost
we urge the parties to break the
senseless dynamic
at the same time we expect all countries
directly or indirectly involved to start
showing genuine interest in a dialogue
for achieving peace
the exclusive pursuit of military
Solutions will inevitably Stoke
long-lasting resentments and a
post-conflict situation of fragility and
instability
Mr President we regret the disbanding of
the fact-finding mission set up by the
United Nations to investigate the
incident of 29 July 2022 in Olympic
even before it was able to begin its
work
impartial scrutiny is essential to
contain the proliferation of false
narratives and prevent such atrocities
from happening again
we encourage the parties to increase
efforts to ensure the security of future
missions of this nature and the
Secretary General to reconsider the
decision
Mr President Brazil reiterates its
commitment to the preservation of
Ukraine's sovereignty and territorial
integrity and to a political solution to
the conflict that takes into account
legitimate security concerns
we also reiterate the call for the
well-being of the civilian population on
both sides of the front line to be
everyone's priority
we welcome turkey's renewed mediation
efforts and encourage other members of
the United Nations to engage in
initiatives that will allow for the
prompt cessation of hostilities in order
to abbreviate the suffering of the
Ukrainian people I thank you
I thank the representative of Brazil for
their statement now I give the floor to
the representative of Ghana
thank you president
I thank you SG Rosemary decalo for her
comprehensive briefing on the security
and humanitarian situations in Ukraine
Ghana appreciates and remains fully
supportive of the crucial work of the
different United Nations agencies to
address the several crisis generated by
the war
10 months of the Russian federation's
war on Ukraine has left many in fear of
the greater evil that lies ahead unless
the war is brought to an end sooner
rather than later
we remain deeply concerned that
bellagency appears to Prevail over a
reasonable approach requiring a move
away from the Battlefront and for the
warring parties to resolve their dispute
through dialogue the prevailing
conditions in Ukraine reinforce the
critical need for the International
Community to intensify efforts towards a
peaceful settlement of the conflict
despite the echoing calls by the members
of this Council and the International
Community the Russian federation's
actions have perpetuated a disregard for
the prohibiting obligations of
international law against the use of
force as it engages in an intense fight
to capture the city of Soledad and many
other parts of the country
the multiple impacts of the war on the
lives of the ukrainians especially women
and children are tragic to say the least
the destruction to civilian and critical
energy infrastructure are Monumental and
require extensive resources to be
restored where possible
we are particularly concerned by recent
escalatory rhetoric and posturing which
carry the risk of a possible spillover
of hostilities and That Could set the
stage for a wider War marked by existing
Global geopolitical features
while Ukraine has been the center stage
of combat the war has also deep
intentions within the interstate
relations of some of the most powerful
Nations and elicited responses ranging
from the imposition of sanctions and
Military assistance to Ukraine
we must also note the continuing impact
of the unfolding war on the world
economy the food energy and financial
crisis provoked by the war has caused
many developing countries to experience
receding economies and heightened
chances of instability
Mr President International Peace and
security are under threat from the
ongoing war in Ukraine
there is a need therefore for the
security Council to strengthen peace
efforts by drawing on the tools for
Pacific settlements provided under the
charter of the United Nations we are of
the view that the security Council must
begin to consider a clear-cut process
involving all the parties and all other
relevant stakeholders
such an effort would require the good
faith commitment of all members of the
council and must be aimed at finding
pragmatic and mutually acceptable
Solutions grounded in the rules of
international law and their vowed values
of the charter of the United Nations
it is most present for the security
Council to find Common Ground upon which
it can accelerate action for peace in
Ukraine
as the body mandated to promote and
maintain International Peace and
security we share a collected burden to
restore peace to Ukraine and its people
we must however point out that a lot
depends on the will of the Russian
Federation to Abate its violations of
the sovereignty political Independence
and territorial Integrity of Ukraine we
therefore we treat our call for an end
to this wall by the immediate and
unconditional withdrawal of the Russian
Federation forces from the
internationally recognized borders of
Ukraine we're a family of the view that
dialogue and diplomacy offer the most
viable parts to address the security and
other concerns of the parties in a
comprehensive and mutual acceptable
manner
Mr President we continue to be
disheartened by the humanitarian
suffering experienced by the people as a
result of the war innocent people pay
the price each day of the war with their
lives and livelihoods millions of people
have been displaced from their homes
with little hope of returning to find
them in place to date close to 7 000
deaths and more than 11 000 injuries
including of children have been recorded
most regrettably humanitarian workers
have also Fallen victim to the war
the deliberate attacks of civilians and
humanitarian workers are unacceptable
and constitute violations under
International humanitarian law
we condemn all such action and call on
the parties to comply with their
International obligations and also to
Grant humanitarian access to all
impacted areas
we condemn all abuses and violations of
human rights arising from the war and we
treat our call for thorough transparent
and independent investigations into all
such reports we note with regrets that
the United Nations fact-finding mission
that was to investigate the killing of
prisoners in olympka has had to be
disbanded for safety reasons despite any
setbacks we must sustain a collective
commitment to ensure accountability for
all war crimes and to avoid impunity in
Ukraine in respect of safety of nuclear
Safety and Security we wish to
underscore the absolute importance for
the parties to take preventive measures
including the delineation of a
demilitarized zone around the separation
nuclear power plant as well as other
nuclear facilities in other parts of the
country we urge the international atomic
energy agency in its engagement with the
parties also to address the concerns
regarding the physical and mental
well-being of the staff at this
operation power plant
finally Mr President let me Express
Ghana's unwavering support for the
sovereignty political Independence and
territorial Integrity of Ukraine we
stand in Readiness to support the
efforts of the council and The Wider
International Community in finding a
comprehensive and Lasting resolution of
the conflict between the Russian
Federation and Ukraine and further to
address the global challenges resulting
for the War I thank you for your kind
attention I thank the representative of
Ghana for their statement now I give the
call to the representative of Russian
Federation
Mr President
well to be frank we don't really
understand very well why today's meeting
was convened
in order to hear a briefing by Madame De
Carlo which was drawn up based on the
so-called reliable information
of uh that it was provided by so-called
independent sources of so-called
independent commission what have we
heard that's new from our Western
colleagues that we haven't heard in
various forms over the past year
the English writer William thackeray
who's well known in our country wrote a
novel called Vanity Fair
well meetings on Ukraine which have been
convened by our former Western Partners
increasingly recall a hypocrisy Fair
and the hypocrisy of Representatives of
the collective West and the Kiev regime
increasingly are taking on the oddest
forms for example our Ukrainian
neighbors who just recently threatened
us with terrible punishment and uh
almost threatened to launch an offensive
against Moscow today have put on the
Garb of peacemakers we felt that
yesterday based on the statements of
Madame japarva and prior to that based
on the initiatives of her boss Mr culeba
Ukraine now is running around
brandishing the idea of some sort of a
peace Summit suggesting any way it can
that it's Russia who doesn't want war
clearly this is a merely an attempt to
win sympathy among Western public who is
increasing who is increasingly asking
inconvenient questions about where the
money provided jakeiv is going and is
surprised why Ukraine is rejecting any
realistic mediation initiatives at first
glance it seems there is the Olive
Branch held out by Kiev what could be
nobler however even with the most
cursory examination it becomes clear
that behind this lovely facade there's a
rotten structure and even a hidden
compartment Kiev does not try to hide
that peace Ally Ukraine is the
capitulation of Russia which must be
endorsed by the International Community
this is why Mr culeba is promoting his
propaganda piece as a stunt initiative
immediately specified that the Russian
participation in the so-called Summit is
not planned now it's based on the same
hypocritical and fundamentally flood
formula that the much wanted zelenski
peace initiative is based on that our
Western colleagues outdid each other in
praising anyone who believed even for a
minute in the peaceful intentions of the
Ukrainian dictator I'd like to remind
them that from the 30th of September the
very possibility of dialogue with our
country was was forbidden by Ukrainian
legislation by decree number
6779 literally Ukraine and I quote noted
them possibility of conducting
negotiations with president of the
Russian Federation Putin end of quote
there's no other way to explain this
legislative provocation other than the
intention to continue fighting to the
last Ukrainian by the way it's difficult
to shed the impression that the Kiev
regime and its most rabid sponsors have
completely forgotten the word the
meaning of the word peace it's no
accident that the European Union is
financing arms deliveries to Kiev
through the European fund uh peace fund
without even considering how abominable
that sounds colleagues Ukrainian
authorities once again have shown their
true and far from peaceful colors in
March of 2022 when it withdrew its own
realistic elements of a peace agreement
which we were ready to discuss whether
Kiev decided on this fateful step by
itself or was heeding the instructions
of its London Washington and Brussels
sponsors is not so important now what's
most important is that precisely then
the key of regime in spite of facts and
Common Sense embrace the illusion that
with the increasing direct support of
NATO it could defeat Russia on the field
of battle now the Ukrainian dictator is
still incapable of shedding this
dangerous illusion even the Western
leaders have adopted a more sober view
of the situation as a result Ukraine has
in essence become a NATO private
military Enterprise it gets money is
supplied with weapons and intelligence
information it's told what to Target and
who to attack those who suffer are the
Ukrainian people who are being forced to
fight for someone else's objectives and
this was acknowledged Yesterday by the
Ukrainian minister of defense and I
quote him we are fulfilling the mission
of NATO without spilling their blood but
spilling our blood this is why wet the
West should continue to give us more
money and more weapons end of quote that
is the formula of NATO of a NATO War by
proxy to the last Ukrainian it's you
can't describe it any better at the same
time this cynical confirmation of the
true premise of any Ukrainian so-called
peace and initiatives
Mr President I'm convinced that after my
statement many colleagues will ask the
legitimate question what is necessary
for peace to Prevail in Ukraine this is
a legitimate question especially in
conditions when the key of regime and
its Western sponsors are trying to
present this situation as though the
goal of the special military operation
in Ukraine is to destroy Ukraine as a
state almost to de-ukronize Ukraine as
it and and forced russification we have
never set such goals it's important to
understand that we are Waging War not
with Ukrainian people but with the uh
criminal nationalist regime which came
to power in 2014 as a result of a
anti-constitutional coup supported by
the West proclaimed the policy of
do-rucifying Ukraine and glorifying Nazi
Collaborators the result of this
criminal policy was an eight year long
war against the inhabitants of dunbas
who who did not want to submit to the
government the main goal of the special
military operation was to and that
eight-year-old War for the inhabitants
of the donuts can lugan's people's
response Republic the war hasn't stopped
for eight years as far as how the
population of that region survived under
the shelling then and now and what the
people of the donbass wanted and how
they tried to achieve that well we
intend to tell everyone about that next
Friday under an aria formula meeting we
think that for all states and first and
foremost members new members of the
council and those interested will it
will be useful to get a first-hand
account from based on the testimony of
witnesses and foreign observers and
journalists who were there now
everything in Ukraine could have
concluded differently if Kiev had
implemented the resolution the Minsk
agreements uh endorsed by the U.N uh
resolution however this did not fit with
the plans of zelensky or its
predecessors and thanks to the
revelations from Chancellor Merkel and
president Hollande did not fit in the
plans of its guarantors France and
Germany furthermore we learned that the
Minsk process was just a cover for what
the West behind which it was arming
Ukraine in order to push it into a
conflict with Russia with the beginning
of this special military operation the
goal is to ensure that no threat will
emanate from the Ukrainian territory for
Russia and the Discrimination of the
Russian uh speaking population will end
if this can be achieved through peaceful
negotiations we're ready to engage if
not we will achieve it through military
means to date though neither the key of
regime nor the West its Western sponsors
have drawn the necessary conclusions
about this disaster further even worse
in Ukraine with the tolerance of the
collective West the zelensky regime has
become an authoritarian dictatorship
which in itself is a significant
obstacle to peace more recently in
addition to persecuting dissidents and
leaders of the opposition we've seen an
attempt to destroy the only canonical
Church in Ukraine the Ukrainian Orthodox
Church
the consequences of such actions for
regional peace and security could be
very severe which is why we believe that
this situation deserves close scrutiny
by the members of the security Council
in this connection we'd like to request
the Japanese presidency to convene a
separate meeting of the security Council
on this topic in the afternoon of the
17th of January thank you
I thank the representative of Russian
Federation for their statement
now I'll give the floor to the
representative of Gabon
thank you Mr President I thank under
Secretary General Rosemary De Carlo
for her briefing I also welcome here
today
the first Deputy foreign minister of
Ukraine
and the deputy Minister for foreign
affairs of Poland I also welcome the
representative of Lithuania
and the head of the delegation of the
European Union to the United Nations
here today Mr President since the last
meeting of this Council on the war in
Ukraine no lull has been noted on the
ground there has been no respite for the
people
the bitter fighting taking place in
Soledad and in bakmut compels us to act
civilians
there are subject to regular shelling
and are gripped in an unbearable Vice
as
they struggle to control every space
according to the most recent statistics
from the United Nations this war has
produced around 6.5 million idps there
have been more than 5 million refugees
produced more than 7 000 civilian deaths
and more than 11 000 injured in addition
there are there have been alleged rapes
alleged acts of sexual violence
infiltration trafficking in person
namely of children and women
children's education has been disrupted
and there have been
consequences and Trauma
which go far beyond the boundaries of
the conflict itself the use of weapons
of mass destruction and in particular
the use of drones and other explosive
weapons with wide area effects as well
as the use of cluster Munitions and
anti-personnel mines has served greatly
to swell the toll of the war in Ukraine
many attacks have targeted energy
infrastructure Health infrastructure
water supply infrastructure and there
have been direct attacks on civilians
such attacks have forced civilians to
flee to
Escape danger and these attacks have
also made it more difficult to
distribute humanitarian Aid to the
millions of people in need the number of
people in need of humanitarian
assistance has spiked as temperatures
have plummeted
we hail the remarkable work of the
humanitarian organizations present in
Ukraine and present in Refugee host
countries their work has been invaluable
to in providing Aid as well as
food cash Medical Care electric
generators drinking water and other
basic Services once again we call upon
the warring parties to uphold the com
their commitments under International
humanitarian law we call upon them to
refrain from using weapons whose
indiscriminate effects inflict atrocious
suffering on civilians Mr President
as we approach the critical juncture of
10 of 12 months of Taylor thwart
it would seem that the rhetoric of the
all-out use of weapons is prevailing
everywhere and that
Heralds fighting which is even more
intense everything points to the fact
that this coming spring will be as this
winter has been a season of increasingly
violent offensive as such it is high
time for the meetings of this Council to
be convened and focused on reaching an
outcome which prior prioritizes the
search for a solution it is now High
time that the channels of diplomacy
become active so that we can put an end
to this bloody war my country calls upon
all parties to throw their full force
behind the Quest for a political
solution and this in order to put an end
to the cycle of suffering and distress
we must ensure that dialogue and
diplomacy Prevail to put an end to the
war in Ukraine thank you the
representative of Gabon for their
statement I now give the floor to the
representative of Malta
thank you president I begin by thanking
on the secretary of the Carla for her
sobering briefing I recognize the
participation of her excellencies
zabarova first Deputy foreign minister
of Ukraine
the heralding of a new year has struck
differently this year with the people of
Ukraine due to the continuation of
Russia's war of aggression
at the start of 2023 we must continue to
prioritize a prolonged and intensifying
nature of this illegal War along with
its consequences on Ukraine its people
Europe and the rest of the world
as we continue to witness a systematic
targeting of critical infrastructure
particularly energy and water
Distribution Systems we condemn this
evident weaponization of winter to the
severe detriment of the civilians in
Ukraine
these attacks have led to widespread
blackouts and the disruption of
essential services in Ukraine and
constitute a violation of international
humanitarian law in particular the four
Geneva conventions and their protocols
we stress that International
humanitarian and international human
rights law must be respected and upheld
at all times without exception
the repercussions of this war on
children must be highlighted attacks on
civilian infrastructure including
schools and transportation systems
coupled with displacements are having a
disproportionate impact on children
their education and their safety
lack of access to basic Services is
depriving them of their fundamental
rights and this will lead to long-term
consequences that will not be easily
reversed
furthermore children have been forcibly
moved to Russia breaking Family Ties and
placing children in vulnerable
situations while denying them the rights
to family life
dire consequences are also true for all
the displaced people and refugees
funding for civil society organizations
in particular women's organizations must
be given priority and OCS sales must be
included and participate meaningfully in
coordination mechanisms and
decision-making processes at all levels
we have heard harrowing testimonies of
rape torture trafficking confirmed by
the international independent Commission
of inquiry on Ukraine in this regard we
welcome the framework of cooperation on
the prevention and response to
conflict-related sexual violence with
the government of Ukraine and the UN
system
we urge rigorous and Swift action with
respect to accountability investigations
prosecutions compensation reparations
and the service provision that is
Survivor centered rights-based and
Trauma informed
once again sexual violence has become a
feature of War we cannot fail to
investigate and prosecute these crimes
we cannot tolerate impunity for sexual
violence and conflict
we call for the safe rapid and unimpeded
humanitarian access and corridors to
anyone in need across Ukraine we commend
the U.N is related agencies and all
humanitarian workers who are working on
the ground in extremely difficult
operational environment and taxing
conditions
over the last few weeks we have
witnessed renewed them for long attacks
on Kiev and other cities
along with suffering inflict along with
the suffering inflicted on the civilian
population we reiterate Our concern
about the respect for international
humanitarian law
and hope that these attacks will cease
immediately the documented Providence of
the uavs used in these attacks raise
serious concerns which need to be
addressed equally I reiterate that
indiscriminate attacks and attacks on
civil critical infrastructure must stop
it is the responsibility of this Council
and all its members to uphold the U.N
Charter and international law without
exception
in closing we welcome USG De Carlos
positive update with regard to the
ongoing contacts regarding prisoners of
war and progress on the Black Sea grain
initiative and we call upon the Russian
Federation to seize all hostilities and
take concrete steps towards solving
contentious issues through dialogue and
diplomacy in ways that are consistent
with the UN Charter thank you
I thank the representative of Malta for
their statement
I now give the floor to the
representative of United Arab Emirates
thank you Mr President and I'd like to
also join others in thanking under
Secretary General De Carlo for her
briefing and extend my Welcome To Her
Excellency zaparova first Deputy foreign
minister of Ukraine and his Excellency
go well Deputy Minister for foreign
affairs of Poland for their
participation
Mr President since last February this
Council has met over the war in Ukraine
more than 40 times
our discussions have covered virtually
every reason to abhor Modern Warfare
from the threat of nuclear confrontation
to the plight of children in conflict
each passing Day last year added to the
urgency of a cessation of hostilities
and the necessity of a negotiated
settlement yet one fighting season has
yielded to another as this terrible
conflict continues and today nearly 40
percent of Ukraine's population needs
humanitarian Aid the ravages of War have
not spared essential Services either
while the onset of winter compounds
civilian suffering as we have heard
donors and Aid groups have responded
with urgency scaling up the delivery of
essential services and providing
thousands of generators to help people
through the winter indeed the uae's aid
program has so far sent 2500 generators
as part of our ongoing humanitarian
response to the conflict
but Aid actors have also been caught in
the crossfire on 15th December a
humanitarian worker was killed while
Distributing food and just a few days
later the office of the Red Cross and
Donetsk was damaged by shelling
this war is already killed at least 7
000 Ukrainian civilians and forced 15
million to flee their homes in September
the World Bank estimated that Ukraine's
reconstruction would cost around 350
billion dollars that was before the
widespread destruction of critical
infrastructure including power plants
and the electricity grid Beyond
Ukraine's borders the war is
contributing to turmoil in the global
supply chain and food and energy markets
and imposing unsustainable costs on
countries in the global South for
low-income developing States the
conflict added to an already difficult
post-pandemic global economy with Rising
prices and interest rates in significant
inflationary pressures nearly 60 percent
of these countries now face a debt
crisis people far from the front lines
in Ukraine are paying a price for this
conflict meanwhile the International
System has had to confront the twin
crises of function and principle the war
in Ukraine has risked entrenching Global
divisions to the point of paralyzing
multilateralism with the false choice of
with us or against us at the same time
the challenges to the most foundational
tenets of international law and the U.N
Charter could not be more explicit
Mr President we all acknowledge that the
war cannot go on for another year of
lives lost and immense suffering the UAE
has consistently held that there is no
viable military solution however we
acknowledge that ultimately it is the
parties Ukraine and the Russian
Federation that must decide when and how
they begin comprehensive talks still the
International Community can and must do
more to accelerate that process through
active and deliberate diplomacy we must
collectively work to prevent an
escalation and expansion of the war and
includes minimizing the risk of a
miscalculation in those efforts we must
also preserve the space for positive
interactions between the two sides at
the very least to normalize engagement
on key areas like the export of grain
and fertilizers nuclear Safety and
Security and respect for international
humanitarian law and to encourage the
parties to the negotiation table we
should also provide incentives in the
form of a post-war Vision that is just
and sustainable
so in 2023 let us leverage the fact that
we share a clear and Urgent interest in
bringing this war to a Swift and
peaceful end equally importantly let all
of our efforts drive at an inclusive and
robust multilateralism which is critical
to addressing urgent Global challenges
but also to safeguarding Ukraine's
sovereignty Independence and territorial
Integrity as well as the Region's
long-term security stability and
prosperity
Mr President today we must work for
something more durable a piece that
holds and endures we must begin to
imagine the day after this war ends
thank you I thank the representative of
United Arab Emirates for their statement
now I give the floor to the
representative of United Kingdom
thank you president and I join others in
thanking under Secretary General De
Carlo for her briefing and welcoming
Among Us Her Excellency jumper over the
first Deputy foreign minister and his
Excellency girl while Deputy Minister
for foreign affairs
this is our first meeting on Russia's
illegal invasion of Ukraine since the
9th of December last year
many of us have spent the time since
then resting recuperating
celebrating with family and preparing
for the new year
Russia
Russia has spent that time bombing
civilians attacking Ukraine's critical
infrastructure
and attempting to seize Ukrainian
territory
as it did for most of last year
Russia has continued to do this
with the assistance of Belarus
and using weapons sourced from Iran and
North Korea in violation of Security
Council resolutions
and with utter contempt for this Council
president
millions of ukrainians
spent the holiday period
Sheltering from missile and drone
attacks
sitting in the dark and the cold
and living as refugees displaced persons
and prisoners
many of them
thousands of miles away from their homes
families and loved ones
as the Secretary General said yesterday
this war has created a humanitarian and
human rights catastrophe
traumatized a generation of children
and accelerated the global food and
energy crisis
as a result
Millions across the world are facing
another year of hunger and hardship
president
as many of us have said repeatedly
Russia
can choose to end all this immediately
by stopping its attacks against Ukraine
not just for 36 hours but for good
and by withdrawing its forces from
Ukraine
while Russia's assault continues however
Ukraine has no choice but to exercise
its right to defend itself
but like the rest of us
what Ukraine wants is a just and
sustainable peace
we welcome and support Ukraine's
initiative to this end
We join the International Community in
again calling for an end to the war
which respects Ukraine's rights under
international law and the U.N Charter
so that this year
may be a year of peace
thank you
I thank the representative of United
Kingdom for their statement
I shall now make a statement in my
capacity as a representative of Japan
I thank Ms Rosemary decalo for her
briefing it is truly regrettable that we
have to repeat what we and other member
states have said many times before in
various occasions
however we are compelled to articulate a
position once again
Japan condemns in the strongest terms
Russia's aggression against Ukraine
which is a clear and flagrant violation
of international law and the United
Nations Charter
by a permanent member of the security
Council which is supposed to Bear heavy
responsibility for the maintenance of
International Peace and security
Russia must immediately stop its war of
aggression withdraw all of its troops
and military equipment from Ukraine and
respect Ukraine's Ukraine's Independence
sovereignty and territorial Integrity
within its internationally recognized
borders in nakodas was a series of
general assembly resolutions and the icj
order on provisional measures
we also condemn Russian attacks against
civilian infrastructure and cities
across Ukraine innocent civilians in
Ukraine including children have been
exposed to strikes
even during the New Year holidays
distractions of energy infrastructure
has seriously aggravated the
humanitarian situation in the harsh
winter
any continuation of these attacks is
completely unacceptable
we recall their indiscriminate attacks
on innocent civilian populations
constitute a war crime
we underline that there can be no
impunity for war crimes and other
atrocities including sexual and
gender-based violence
the International Community must hold
these responsible those responsible to
account in accordance with international
law
we strongly condemn the transfer of
amount aerial vehicles from Iran to
Russia we would support efforts by the
U.N Secretariat to investigate the
potential usage of Iranian drones by
Russia in its war against Ukraine in
accordance with the U.N security Council
resolution 2231
we also strongly condemn Russia's
irresponsible nuclear rhetoric and its
seizure and militarization of zaphrisia
nuclear power plant we fully support the
work of iaea to ensure a nuclear Safety
and Security at the znpp
Japan reaffirms its commitment to play
its part in shielding vulnerable
countries that are severely impacted by
the repercussions of Russia's war of
aggression against Ukraine and Russia's
weaponization of energy and food
we welcome the agreement by all parties
to continue a cooperation on the Black
Sea grains initiative and reiterate our
respect for therefore to be un Secretary
General guterres and turkey in this
regard we strongly urge the relevant
countries to continue to steadily
implement this initiative
Universal attempts to change the status
quo by force shake the very foundation
of the international order based on the
rule of law and must not occur at any
corner of the growth
members did we have found such
principles at the open debate yesterday
Japan renews our full resolve to
continue our assistance to support
Ukraine's defense over its sovereignty
and territorial Integrity we will stand
firmly with Ukraine for as long as it
takes
I shall now
support Ukraine's defense of its
sovereignty and territorial Integrity we
will stand firmly with the Ukraine for
as long as it takes
I shall now make
before a minister of Ukraine
[Music]
members of the security Council and the
Secretary General DeCarlo dear friends
their colleagues
I would like to start with the words of
my huge personal appreciation to all of
you
who Express support to Ukraine in our
fight for the Existence and not only in
our fight for the Existence but also for
the existence of the whole world that is
based on rules and Order international
law respect for the very fundamental
things that we know like territorial
integrity and sovereignty and finally
respect for the human dignity and
freedom
I regret that the Evil's messenger is
still here
in the city of the permanent member of
the U.N security Council
the seat of the Soviet Union
this Representatives constantly poisoned
the discussion held here in cynically
lie to all of us
I reiterate what the delegation of my
country has already pointed out that the
legal grounds for such a presence are
more than dubious If Not absent
Mr President dear colleagues since the
last council meeting on the Russian war
against Ukraine the situation on the
ground has further deteriorated
active Frontline with Russia is more
than 105 1500 kilometers while the total
combat line is almost 4 000 kilometers
Ukraine has been turned into the world's
largest minefield
of 175 000 square kilometers the
majority of Russian missile and drone
attacks has been directed at civilian
infrastructure namely 62 percent of all
strikes
thousands of residential buildings
houses schools kindergartens hospitals
museums religious buildings electricity
greets water greets Railway markets have
been either destroyed or heavily damaged
over 7 million of my compatriots mostly
women and children have been roaming all
around the globe from there been
separated from their homes and Families
and more than other 7 million of
ukrainians have become idps
eternally displaced persons and this is
on the top of 1.5 million of idps since
2014 like myself when I left my homeland
Crimea
today the battle for donbass is at City
at Ace hate
the cities of Bahamut and Soledad are
now the major hot spots of the military
action what happens there surpasses the
most horrific picture of world wars
there are ruins instead of residential
buildings emptiness and dead bodies
instead of Joyful crowds chair tree
trunks instead of forests
and moon-like surface instead of grain
fields ladies and gentlemen
I think it's our shared responsibility
to restore peace and Justice to make
every provision of the U.N Charter
operational
to guarantee safe and prosperous future
to our children to our grandchildren and
all generations to come it is our
historic Mission and its amongment in
where we live all together
my president followed has initiated
peace formula to meet the pressing
challenges of the world
it consists of 10 points that are able
to bring back security and Justice to
Ukraine and the entire world the formula
is quite simple and it's based on the
purposes and principles of the U.N
Charter as we all see the Russia's War
impacts the entire world because today
our states and peoples are very much
interconnected when Russia destroys
Greenfield and farms in Ukraine families
from many countries
in need suffer from food shortages and
poverty
thus our peace formula is aimed at
ensuring Security in all its Dimensions
food security radiation nuclear safety
energy security countering echocyte and
preventing repetition of the aggression
we all need to develop enhanced security
guarantees to ensure that the tragedy
will never repeat
we call on the responsible Nations to
facilitate and promote the peace formula
plan excellences we also should be
United in strengthening our further
pressure on Russia to destroy its War
Machine
the aggressive state has already felt
the impact of sanctions even though they
denied
it's invading Army is running out of
modern weapons and ammunition and
although we haven't won yet Russia has
already lost
for its final defeat and victory for of
our democracies another joint action is
needed in this regard my message is very
clear we need to reinforce sanctions in
sector of particular economic importance
to Russia full oil and gas embargo
disconnection of Russian Banks from
Global Financial system is price the
aggressor State should pay you
as Russian finds itself in total
isolation
it has to intensify it ties with other
barriers Moscow irresponsibly gets them
ever more involved in his bloody war we
could not allow those who assist Russia
in committing its horrific war crimes
avoid responsibility it is applicable
both to Belarus that hypocritically
denies its actual participation in the
war and Iran that supplies its drones to
Russia which continue to be an
indispensable mean of Russian missile
Terror strategy
Ukraine has official requested the U.N
Secretary General and U.N Secretariat
more than once to send experts to
Ukraine to investigate Iran's supplies
of unmanned aerial vehicles
to Russia Today I retrieved this request
and I hope that the mission will be
dispatched as soon as possible because
the delay undermines The credibility of
the security Council as such as well as
its ability to ensure implementation of
its own decision in particular the U.N
security Council resolution 20 to 31.
colleagues
our efforts to restore peace and
security cannot be complete without
steps to ensure Justice
this is why it is matter of Paramount
importance to establish special tribunal
to hold Russia what criminals
accountable in almost 11 months the
aggressive state has already committed
over 64
000 registered war crimes and I dread to
think
how many more mass Graves like kombucha
in a zoom in Limon we will be able to
discover after full liberation of our
territories
this terrifying crimes would not be
possible without so-called mother of all
crimes which is crime of aggression that
started in my native Crimea in 2014 and
I would like to share with you a very
personal story of mine that happened in
March 2014 when I lived in Crimean I was
a journalist and I traveled the whole
peninsula in order to collect evidences
of the Russian crime of aggression and
we were supposed to be briefed by the
special Envoy of the U.N Secretary
General Dutch Ambassador Robert sarri
and he was not there for two hours and
there was a rumor that he was kidnapped
that he was seized by the so-called
self-defense guys and I was actually the
first to find him in mother in one of
the cafeterias in the center of the
simple and I became a communicator
between the FSB actually and and himself
and he was put on the ultimatum to leave
Crimea as soon as possible and then the
last message that he gave me when we
were together in the simple airport
because we were took by FSB there in in
Convoy in Convoy by full equipped people
and then he said I will report to the
Secretary General all of the details of
this issue of this his travel because he
was not able to exercise his mandate and
this is exactly what has been happening
while Russia has been declaring its
openness for any access of international
delegations monitoring missions like
innolenifka they in fact do not and are
not opened for monitoring because they
are dreaming of hiding their own crimes
and we of course with the lenifka as far
as we gave all of the necessary
guarantees to have a Nexus and fact-mind
finding Mission we regret that Russia
failed to do so
the international criminal court in the
heck which investigates Russian crimes
against Ukraine does not have sufficient
jurisdiction and power for the
persecution of the Russian aggression
and thus we believe that the only way to
restore Justice is the establishment of
this International mechanism or special
tribunal your support of the respective
resolution is a sign of Hope for every
single Ukrainian whose life was
dramatically affected by Russia's War
ladies and gentlemen my next point is
dedicated to defense assistance and
weapon
air defense systems are still a top
priority as Russia keeps its missile
Terror all across Ukraine as a result
almost half of our energy infrastructure
is damaged
millions of ukrainians have to spend
their evenings and nights by candlelight
because they have no electricity
for its part Ukraine even being under
unprecedented attack keeps to share not
only values and dignity but also
something very practical like for
example the initiative grain from
Ukraine and I think to the UN and number
of our partners for supporting this
humanitarian initiative of my president
it is clear that there is no room for
compromise with evil because if Ukraine
stops fighting
it will die
the world as we know it will die
if Russia stops its aggression the war
will end it is as simple as that
however even after the victory there
will be many challenges to address
according to the latest estimates that
we have the total amount of damage
caused by Ukraine's civil and critical
infrastructure is is more than 127
billion dollars
the recovery of Ukraine will be one of
the largest investment projects now
Ukraine has become the biggest
construction site in Europe that
provides a wide range of multiple
opportunities for international Partners
to implement the best practices in the
sphere of engineering construction and
transfer of Technologies
the sooner Ukraine recovers the Sunnah
Ukraine could again fully Focus as a
reliable partner and active contributor
on resolving the global challenges such
as climate change food insecurity
poverty conflicts and many other that
affect the daily life of hundreds of
millions of people all around the world
dear friends
everyday life of people in Ukraine today
looks exactly as what the U.N has
committed to counter and overcome war
and insecurity lack of access to basic
things like water and electricity
poverty and environmental degradation
for many in my country and for many of
you life in my country might seem
unimaginable with cooking on firewood
saving water in plastic bottles to drink
to wash dishes to flush the toilet
reading and making homework by the
candlelight making laundry in a basin
healthy work instead of elevator into 20
plus something floor
sleeping dressed in a coat hat and
gloves
hiding from bombs in the shelters
and these are the problems for many
vulnerable countries that the upcoming
sdg Summit as well as the summit of the
future are supposed to address and I
could keep on reflecting on this
medieval lifestyle in my country but my
big point is absolutely different
you could hardly find someone who
complains
everyone is like a Ukrainian soldier in
the trench
we manifest dignity despite all threats
and all I would say inconveniences
we live our lives with dignity
cherishing our unity and ability to
resist
cheering up by words of love and support
sharing food and clothes and candles
mourning Our Heroes rejoicing newborns
we became
people and we're happy to see people on
the streets and I feel happy when I
immediate in the traffic jam can you
imagine that one can be happy to be in a
traffic jam
we are now becoming experts on
generators and the most common wish at
the New Year Eve and Christmas Eve was
the victory
the victory of Ukraine is not only the
biggest wish of millions of my
competitors who stood against idea to
say neocolonialism and restoration of
Empire and have been fighting for its
independence with no fear anymore
it is the common goal for those who
understand that if the bigger attacks
smaller no one in this room and thus in
your irrespective countries can feel
secured
however we can make it secured by
working together shoulder to shoulder
hand to hand heart to heart we can make
it I thank you for your attention
I think Her Excellency Mr japalova for
her statement
I give the floor to his Excellency Mr
Vietnam for for foreign affairs of
Poland
and your Excellency Mr President dear
ministers honorable delegates
Poland comments Japan for convening this
important meeting
let me express my appreciation to your
Excellency Mr President for your
statement and to under Secretary General
Rosemary DeCarlo for her briefing
and valuable insights
thank you for to your Excellency I mean
japarova for your statement or for your
testimony about the the the
Dignity
of the Ukrainian people which you so
eloquently evoke
Mr President
with each and every day of its
aggression against Ukraine
Russia is breaking the most basic rules
and principles of international law
enshrined in the U.N Charter and other
historic documents
we are obliged to repeat this plain fact
over and over again
even though it falls on the aggressors
that ears
today I would like to make three points
regarding the current situation in
Ukraine
first
I wish to assure you that Poland will
continue to act as the assistance hub
for Ukraine as long as it is necessary
we have been proud to offer our Goodwill
services to Ukraine and ukrainians from
day one of the Russian invasion
in addition to offering shelter to
millions of Ukrainian refugees
Poland keeps providing the and
facilitating transfers of
multi-dimensional Aid as well as hosting
several hundred humanitarian workers
from over a dozen U.N agencies an
international organizations
we are the main support Gateway for
Ukraine
and it is Our intention to continue in
this particular role as long as it is
required
a second
I would like to inform you about the
conclusions of the Lublin triangle
Summit of the presidents of Ukraine
Poland Lithuania which took place in
levith just two days ago
in their John in their joint declaration
the three leaders underlined among other
things their full support for the
creation in accordance with the
principles of international law
of an ad hoc International Tribunal for
the crime of aggression committed by the
Russian Federation against Ukraine
the presidents also voiced their support
for the convening for convening the
Global Peace formula Summit initiated by
Ukraine in order to consolidate
International support as presented by
president zawanski
Poland and Lithuania also reconfirmed
their strong advocacy for Ukraine's
euro-atlantic perspective
Mr President
and last but not least my final point is
an appeal to the members of this
Security Council and the whole
International Community
it is my duty to express in this chamber
Poland's concern
with the role of Belarus in the Kremlin
strategy regarding Ukraine
by now we already know that Minsk is
politically and practically supporting
the Russian aggression
however accelerating
Russian military buildup in Belarus
including recently announced Bill
Russian Belarusian military drills to
take place between January 16th and
February 1st should ring
additional alarm Bells
I do not have to remind anybody here
that the deployment of Russian troops
and military equipment in Belarus just
16 in just 12 months ago was a Prelude
to a full-scale Invasion we have
witnessed since February 24th 2022
the concentration of troops
in our region
is a negative development which we
notice
therefore we should make clear to
Belarus that it is that it can still
reverse its course and make the right
choice Minsk has to be conscious that
it's further active involvement in the
invasion will be met with firm response
from the International Community
let us make every effort to prevent
further escalation of the conflict and
use all the available tools to establish
a just peace Ukraine Ukraine strives for
thank you I thank his Excellency Mr
galvel for his statement
I now give the floor to the
representative of Lithuania
thank you Mr President
I am delivering this statement on behalf
of the Baltic states Estonia Latvia and
my own country Lithuania
I think I'm the Secretary General
Rosemary DeCarlo for her briefing and
the presidency of Japan for the
opportunity to address this Council
today's date is a symbolic for us as on
January 13th in Lithuania we commemorate
the freedom Defenders day
on this day in 1991 Lithuanian people
including myself student armed against
Soviet tanks defending lithuania's
Independence and freedom
each year we the Baltic states
commemorate all our victims who died in
fight for the independence from the
Soviet Empire and continue to stand with
Ukraine today that today is defending
not only Ukraine but also our freedom
Mr President we are fast approaching a
morbid Milestone one year anniversary of
Russia's unprovoked unjustified and the
legal work of aggression against Ukraine
as we speak the Russian troops continue
systematic and massive attacks on
civilians as well as deliberate
destruction of Ukrainian vital
infrastructure committing horrible war
crimes in Ukraine daily
this clearly demonstrates brutality and
Desperation of Russia's regime if not
stopped Russia will continue threatening
rules-based International order and
pursuing its imperialist and Colonial
Ambitions to retain Ukraine in its
sphere of influence reverse is not
stopped countries around the world will
continue to experience the consequences
of this world including through the
acute food and energy insecurity
we reiterate that Russia is solely
responsible for these hardships by
starting the war of aggression in
blatant violation of the U.N Charter and
its key principles
Lithuania Estonia and Latvia fully
supports Ukraine's initiative on the
establishment of the special Tribunal
for the punishment of the crime of
aggression against Ukraine there must be
no impunity for Russia's crimes
committed on Ukrainian soil
Mr President we commend the people of
Ukraine for the admirable courage in
defending the country the international
legal order and the U.N Charter
the International Community must
continue doing everything possible to
help Ukraine to win this world and to
get through this winter including
through urgently providing specialized
energy equipment and helping to repair
destroyed energy infrastructure
the Baltic states will continue to
provide support to address the impact of
Russia's systemic and deliberate attacks
on Ukraine's energy sector as well as
other official assistance
our countries are among the largest
supporters of Ukraine per capita
together providing more than 1.3 billion
euros in official assistance to Ukraine
since February 2022. and that excluding
private initiatives
we have been assisting vulnerable
communities in the conflict-turned
Eastern regions for the past eight years
and have scaled up our assistance to
meet the massive and Urgent relief and
protection needs for civilians across
the Ukraine since last February
in order to help Ukrainian people to get
through this winter our governments
civil society and private companies have
already sent significant amount of
equipment to Ukraine including power
generators power Transformers and
experience parts
before any Latvian Lithuania and the
European Union will continue to take the
work towards the on the options to use
the Frozen Russian assets to support
Ukraine's reconstruction and for the
purposes of operation in line with
international law
we must ensure the principles
aggressives face the damages fully
implemented in practice
Mr President Baltic states support all
meaningful efforts to bring Russia's
work of aggression to an end we welcome
the 10 steps peace formula proposed by
the president of Ukraine which we
consider as a sound basis for achieving
peace in Ukraine any solution to
Russia's aggression against Ukraine must
ensure that Ukraine's voice is heard and
that the sovereignty Independence unity
and the territorial Integrity of Ukraine
within this International recognized
borders is respected
as the International Community we must
continue to demand every single day that
Russia stops this brutal aggression our
position is clear we will support
Ukraine and defend the principles of U.N
Charter as long as it is necessary
we are confident that Ukraine will
prevail as this was powerful powerfully
conveyed To Us by the first Deputy
Minister Eminem I thank you Mr President
I thank the representative rutheania for
their statement
I now give the floor to his excellent
semester all of skook head of the
European Union to the United Nations
thank you very much Mr President good
afternoon colleagues I have the honor to
speak on behalf of the European Union
and this member states the candidate
country's North Macedonia Montenegro
Albania Ukraine Republic of Moldova and
Bosnian azegovina potential candidate
country Georgia as well as Norway and
Andorra align themselves with this
statement and I want to thank Rosemary
DeCarlo as everyone else have done and
and thank you Mr President for the
opportunity to say a few words on this
very important topic but first I wanted
to acknowledge
and pay tribute to the participation and
the testimony today of the Deputy
foreign minister of Ukraine and I think
she's made an incredibly powerful
statement about how the struggle of the
Ukrainian people is and should be the
struggle of every free country and every
member of the of the United Nations Mr
President Russia decided has decided to
violate one of the most basic principles
of international law and launched a
fully-fledged war of aggression against
its neighbor a fellow member of this
organization the courage and resilience
of the Ukrainian people in their Darkest
Hour inspired the world and we came
together also here at the UN to condemn
this unprovoked aggression and defend
the U.N Charter
in 2023 not even two weeks into the new
year Russia continues its brutal attacks
on civilians and critical infrastructure
in the midst of winter
so in response we must continue to stand
together with Ukraine and in defense of
the founding principle of this
organizations and as members of the
security Council we call on all of you
to assume your responsibility in
upholding the charter and in defense of
International Peace and security
today as Russia's Onslaught against the
people of Ukraine persist I'd like to
highlight and I think we all should
highlight three points one the need to
protect civilians second the importance
of accountability and third our support
to all meaningful initiatives towards a
just peace
first the members of the UN are bound by
international law to protect civilians
Russia's ongoing campaign of systematic
airstrikes against civilian targets and
critical infrastructure must stop
these cruel inhumane attacks only aim to
increase human suffering and deprive
Ukrainian people and Emergency Services
of electricity Heating and water attacks
against civilians and civilian
infrastructure add to the growing
evidence that Russia is committing war
crimes as has been reported by the
independent International Commission of
inquiry on Ukraine
the EU is intensifying our provision of
humanitarian Aid and civilian protection
assistance and our support to the
restoration of Ukraine's critical
infrastructure to help Ukraine get
through the winter we've also responded
with additional restrictive measures
against Russia as well as against Iran
in response to the delivery of drones
and their deadly deployment in Russia's
war of aggression
we call again on Russia to ensure
unimpeded humanitarian access to all
areas under temporary control as well as
to persons detained by Russia and those
forcibly transferred to Russia
the contamination of land mines and
remnants of War Left Behind were
Russia's Armed Force forces is not only
posing a serious obstacle to relief and
the aid delivery efforts but it's
they're also a serious threat to the
lives of civilians and particular
children
second Mr President there can be no
impunity Russia's War has brought death
and destruction to its neighbor the EU
welcomes all efforts to ensure full
accountability for war crimes and the
other most serious crimes in connection
with Russia's War including ways to
secure accountability for the crime of
aggression
Russia must bear the legal consequences
for all violations of international law
and accountability in its broader sense
must be ensured including victims rights
to truth and reparations as well as
guarantees of non-repetition
we support the investigations by the
prosecutor of the ICC the EU has and we
reiterate the order
of the international court of justice of
March of last year for Russia to
immediately suspend its military
operations Ukraine we call on Russia to
comply with this legally binding order
we will continue to support Ukraine in
the framework of the icj proceedings
thirdly we support all meaningful
efforts to bring an end to Russia's War
the path to peace is for the aggressor
to withdraw its troops and military
equipment from the entire territory of
Ukraine and respect its sovereignty and
territorial Integrity We Stand ready to
support Ukraine's Initiative for just
peace to date Russia has not shown any
genuine willingness for a fair and
sustainable peace in line with the this
Charter or the charge of this
organization nor of international law
Russian troops have continued their
Relentless airstrikes against civilians
using cold and hunger's weapons of war
it has blocked any meaningful action by
this Security Council to react to all
these crimes Mr President in closing I
want to reaffirm for the EU its full
support for Ukraine's independent
sovereignty and territorial Integrity we
will continue to stand with ukrainians
people for as long as it takes we will
continue to increase the collective
pressure together with our International
Partners on Russia to end its war of
aggression and to withdraw its troops
and we will continue to be at the
Forefront of global efforts to address
all the global consequences of this
Russian aggression and we count on the
members of the council to do the same I
thank you very much I thank his
Excellency Mr skook for his statement
there are no more names inscribed on the
list of speakers
the meeting is adjourned